hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute
is that a rifle you don't know what a
rifle looks like it did sort were your
thing and gun for mine but I guess we
both doing guns now I just didn't know
that
I see it within you there jealousy
betrayal is it our duty to cleanse the
universe of this weakness
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
dude I'm using my wrong I put your
seatbelt on
[Music]
so it's saving the galaxy again we're
really gonna be able to jack up our
price it for two-time galaxy Davis
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
I
[Applause]
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life
it's right there by your side all wrong
you're right oh you can with y'all
[Music]
the family
listen
[Applause]
after all these years I've found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad
hey everybody its charlie new guardians
footage let's break it down let's do
this frame by frame but first we got to
freak out about Kurt Russell showing up
in there what a coincidence that I did a
video all about the backstory of egos a
living planet or is it a coincidence but
there is a new round of the Marvel
giveaway I'm giving away those Hasbro
spider-man figures all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so let's do it
we finally get a good shot at egos a
living planet really that's the end of
the trailer so I guess maybe we're doing
this in Reverse just a little bit so
even though you might think that this is
his surface unadulterated
this looks more like The Enclave planet
there's a true villains of the film
that's sort of what this trailer reveals
is that they're dedicated to rooting out
all these crazy emotions in the galaxy
jealousy fear so we already know a
couple of plot details this creature
that they're fighting here is sort of
like the medium bad like they get hired
to get rid of this it's called the a
ballistic it's sort of a
multi-dimensional creature that by James
Gunn's explanation doesn't think of
itself as bad like people asked if it
was a big villain in the movie and he's
like well it doesn't think that it's bad
so I think he's just winking at the idea
of egos a living planet being a bit of a
villain in the comics sometimes and
sometimes he works with the heroes like
Thor in fact the first time that Thor
met ego the Living Planet ego showed up
for the first time in authority comic
Thor was hired by another group of
aliens to kill ego to get rid of him
Thor beat him and he banished him back
to the black galaxy where he came from
but that's kind of like the story in the
Guardians trailer here where the enclave
hires the guardians to get rid of the a
bolused but then it goes sideways in the
enclave themselves we've genetically
engineered people that are actually
grown in cocoons just like Adam warlock
turn on them and they sound like they
uncover a plot for them to wipe out all
these emotions in the galaxy and that's
where it goes crazy with all these
starships here like okay we're going to
get rid of all the things that we think
aren't perfect so what is more imperfect
than the family that is the guardians of
the galaxy that's the whole thing -
we're not friends we're family so it's
all about what you would do for your
family and then throwing into the next
ego the Living Planet who also has his
own agenda - so I don't think of him as
a villain in the movie
but he's going to be just this huge
force that star-lord has to contend with
does he pick his father his biological
family which is actually where they are
right here they're on egos surface while
he's also in his human form so they'll
probably explain how his consciousness
transfer words because logistically it
sounds like a nightmare but it's
actually really cool in the comics I
love the star-lord gear here looks like
something out of Star Wars or like a
1970s movie or is like a graphing
calculator from the 70s to super retro
more jokes about the gun the a ballistic
manifest looks like baby Groot actually
does plug in the music during their
fight that's going to be weird the song
might be different like they have the
Fleetwood Mac the chain song but it
might be different in the actual movie
they always cut trailer scenes that
never make it into the final cut of a
film a lot more scenes as of Ravagers
turning on the guardians and then later
then turning on yondu the way Jane's
gonna explain it because you see yondu
escaping from the Ravagers is it the
Ravagers are actually really terrifying
mercenary group but taser face feels
like yondu's gone too soft so e issues a
coup takes over and throws yondu in
prison with these others so they have to
escape and that creates the impetus for
yondu to travel with the Guardians and
then the enclave hires the Ravagers to
go after the Guardians so it's kind of
surprising James Gunn's explained this
much as a plot but that part of the plot
isn't super important is really just him
nailing the characters in the movie
being fantastic you know you need a
great story but if the characters don't
work then it's going to be a terrible
experience inappropriate rocket oh it's
funny love baby group who looks like
he's eating mmm in this seat while
they're in the middle of a firefight
with the Enclave
I love the Ravagers of the group so the
way they're using them in this movie as
antagonist makes a lot easier to rake
them across the coals like they get to
beat the crap out of all these
characters is interesting as they are
they didn't go too deep into the
Ravagers during the first film and they
weren't so much antagonist as they were
just like a group of people that
star-lord had been working with there's
the idea that they might have been able
to save the galaxy once they're super
overconfident but can they do it again
save the galaxy from the Enclave is
really what they're referring to but the
whole idea is that they're super
overconfident after their big victory in
the last movie in that arrogance
sort of gets them into trouble with the
enclave teasing a little bit of Gamora
it was like a brief period where she
hooked up with star-lord but they were
like a huge couple in the comics this
all looks like it's still happening on
that perfect Enclave planet remember
their race is all about genetic
perfection perfection in all things
Gamora with her perfect giant gun love
all these fight sequences the colors are
amazing this is one of the most colorful
Marvel films that I think I've ever seen
that was one of the big criticisms
against their earth-based films that the
way they were edited looked like they
were kind of washed out so the colors
didn't stand out this is almost like the
answer to that like oh you thought there
was no color we're going to give you all
the colors all at the same time red was
actually a really important color for
the first guardians film but a little
more of mantis on egos a living planet
it looks like the planet itself is
breaking up he can actually heal himself
like gain mass by consuming other
planets but it's actually a pretty big
task I love all the nebula here too
especially that moment with Drax where
she chuckles after he's like well we're
all family but maybe maybe not her so
it's kind of like she does feel like
she's family a little bit but she's so
hard chord that it doesn't feel like
she's going to be on the team for
forever even if she's able to reach an
agreement with them like I'm not going
to kill you when I see you but I'm also
not going to be your super best friend
this is the inside of ego the Living
Planet ship more on the enclaves planet
this looks like it's the surface of ego
the Living Planet blowing up and then
who's your daddy I love that Kurt
Russell mustache and beard there were
actually toys that were released last
week pictures that showed exactly what
he looked like so you guys might have
known about this for a while but this is
actually footage that they screened at
Comic Con they actually screened off
this scene where he meets star-lord but
it was unfinished like the CG wasn't
finished the editing wasn't done so it
didn't look as good as it did here but
it's the same basic scene so let me know
in the comments what do you guys think
about this this is more of a story based
trailer that spells out what's going on
who the guardians are actually going to
be fighting against like they were
fighting against Ronan he was the big
villain of the first film even though
Stannis was in it this trailer has them
fighting the a bolused but he's not the
true villain of the film it's these guys
the Infinity gem was a big makeup and
but now it looks like the big wrinkle
the Infinity gem level wrinkle is his
father
but James Gunn did explain no Thanos no
infinity gems in this movie so whatever
process it is that he uses to give
himself as human form it has
nothing to do with the soul gem but
there was actually a really cool story
in the comics where ego the Living
Planet himself contains the essence of
Nemesis which is the soul that's created
when you combine all of the infinity
gems so it's almost like having a
seventh infinity gem inside of him but
that was sort of out of continuity it
didn't have anything to do with a Thanos
Infinity Gauntlet storyline from the
comics it was something that was totally
different but I do like the idea though
that he has an infinity gem inside of
him but wherever the soul gem is is
going to show up somewhere during Thor
or the beginning of infinity war or even
the Black Panther movie so I feel like
now we're at the point where we're just
like checking the boxes off like okay we
got to this movie
no infinity gem okay probably going to
happen in the next movie but let me know
if there any bonus videos you guys want
me to do for guardians or other Marvel
videos there's a spider-man homecoming
kingpin video that I was going to do
that will probably happen later this
week but I just posted an ego the Living
Planet explainer so I'll add a link for
that at the end of this and
congratulations to last week's
spider-man giveaway winner Micah
Montgomery please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round inserted in this video so I'll
announce the winners the next time I
post a Marvel video while you wait to
that you can click here to learn all
about ego the Living Planet history in
the comics and you can click here for my
flash episode thank you so much for
watching
what's that five I'll see you guys in
the next video
you